follow your question for Chris and me
okay how are y'all doing today
better than a desert ground can we help
another question I need your advice
my uncle I'm trying to get a new car
I've had a car for like five or six
years and it's just like not worth
putting the money into anymore and so I
was looking to get a new car so I need a
cosigner to get the new car and my uncle
has agreed that he will cosign on the
car if you think that it was a good idea
for me to get a new car based off my
income and my living arrangements and
everything Bella I have to apologize to
you you've been set up
I've been set up yeah your uncle knew
what I was going to say I wasn't trying
to make is he knows I get anxiety and I
mom I was like I'm about to be blood red
and my heart's not be red no I'm not I'm
not going to take you down on the air
you're okay I'm gonna be sweet to you
okay
does he completely messed you over
because he knew 1,000% that I was going
to say not to do this and he's trying
he's trying to let me be the bad guy cuz
he didn't want to be the bad guy but he
knew when he sent you to me that you
were not going to get this deal out of
me okay and here's what's important more
than your own colon and we can have some
fun with that you and I'll laugh about
it but what's important is what's the
best thing for Bella yep that's what's
important
okay how old are you unbowed between
work good for you good for you well my
youngest is 23 and I've got kids in
their 20s okay so what would I do if my
daughter came in and sat down and said
that over a cup of coffee I need a new
car my old cars worn out and I really
want to go borrow the money to do it and
I want to get a cosigner what would I
say to her because I love my daughter
right mm-hmm
and what I would say to her is the best
thing you can do to build wealth and it
gets financial stability in your life is
to completely avoid car payments now
what that does is it delays your plan
because you kind of got car fever right
now once you once you start once you
start looking at new cars you kind of
get the fever don't you well I hadn't
even literally start with him today's
it's like the second car because my dad
put on $1,000 in my car about five
months ago and it's changing
anything so how much tournament do what
how much do you make I really I just
start working at Cheesecake Factory if
you know what any of those are we're
really good money there and make a round
450 a week and that's why we're slow
right now we're about to pick up one
foot the holidays come around something
and so are you are you living at home
yeah I live at home with my mom I mean I
want more what's your current what's
your current car worth my current car if
I were to trade it in today it's only
like 1,500 or if you were to if you
didn't write it in anymore
if you didn't trade it in because we're
probably they probably just going to
sell it you probably get 2,000 for it if
you put it on Craigslist yeah because
it's Salvage Japan rebuild it because it
was my mom's car to me when I turned 16
okay I mean it's not worth a lion that's
worth 2,000 that's a lot if I handed you
$2,000 you'd smile yeah okay so that's
where that's pretty good now how much
can you save a month if you went crazy
and saved the most you could possibly
save making 450 a week living at home
and well my bowing problem really is i
buy food that's what it literally all I
said I'm not sure how much can you save
can you save $1,000 a month I think
that's my mom's been challenging make a
shoe sometimes make $5,000 a month can
you do that I had it up like $900 I
think you can get it up to thousand a
month if you stay out of running around
with your friends at night oh okay I
don't even do that I don't know that's
why you laughed yeah I know okay so yeah
so listen so $2,000 plus $1,000 a month
for three months that's Christmas it's
three months from now and you'd have
$5,000 to buy a little better car than
you got now and then you keep and then
you keep saving $1,000 a month and this
time next year you could buy a $12,000
car plus the 5,000 other car you got
that's a $17,000 car buy a Christmas a
year later does that make sense to you
if you do that you'll stay out of car
payments because car payments make
people broke and keep them broke and
your uncle loves you enough and he knew
that he was just um didn't want to tell
you no one he wanted me to tell you know
what I need to meet bad guy yeah so I
was a pretty good bad guy though enough
yeah well I didn't okay one
too bad Chris what do you want to add to
that Bella just count yourself very
lucky not only do you have your uncle
you also have Dave and you also have the
person who asked you to go get a cosign
because what they did was they put a big
warning light said you should not get
this and by asking for a cosigner so
you've got three people telling you you
should not do this and you also have a
great situation where you can save a lot
of money so the cool thing is is when
you go to buy this car this now because
we're sure that you're going to follow
this advice you're actually going to own
it the bank's NARM which is pretty darn
cool and it just changes the whole
dynamic of your life the borrower is
slave to the lender when you have a car
payment you know that more than any
other time you know it car payments are
the biggest things we have other than
house payments and it'll just slow down
your whole life kiddo so please don't do
that and your uncle was wise and he
cares about you
even though he did set you up
you